bonjour nicolas bonjour chez olivier
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver dans
la matinale de rtl france alors marlène
schiappa on le disait suggère que
l'animateur cyril hanouna se chargent du
débat d'entre deux tours de la
présidentielle
la polémique s'est fait une place dans
les bars médiatique bien entendu alors
marlène schiappa gerlier n'arrête plus
de nous étonner d'animer la vie
politique française avec cette foule
bien entendu et 7 en train qui la
caractérise elle est un peu avec celle
finalement le bureau des idées
saugrenues dollar m et en un an de la
présidentielle je vous le concède il
n'est pas certain qu emmanuel macron lui
avait besoin d'eux pour éviter un promo
fera de plus en plus probables ou
possibles n'arrivera pas et aussi la
ministre déléguée de la citoyenneté
c'est qu'un tantinet important me
semble-t-il da citoyenneté alors elle
prend des positions courageuses et
suggèrent des améliorations pour remplir
notre vide démocratique en ces temps de
troubles de crise sanitaire de crise
économique et de crise sociale et
dernièrement en famille de la
citoyenneté nous a gratifié vous l'avez
dit d'une idée très étonnante et qui va
donner assurément de l'espoir à chaque
français faire animer le débat
présidentiel par cyril hanouna et elle
n'est pas à son coup d'essai rappelez
vous viviez en 2019 maria bals animés
avec cyril hanouna sur l'émission
balance mon poste une émission consacrée
au gilet jaune est là le vandale remet
les couverts presque deux ans plus tard
rien de tel pour apaiser ce pays en
proie à une tension sociale et populaire
inédite
alors chers français soyez rassurés
dormez tranquilles mal échappa à la
solution alors plus sérieusement cette
proposition marine chabat a le mérite
d'être un excellent thermomètre de
considération que porte une certaine
partie de la caste politique pour les
français olivier alors nicolas qu'est ce
que cette proposition en tout cas nous
dit du débat démocratique
cela nous mène sur la piste longue pire
du bien divertissant pour et à tullow
pointe de gober l'élection
présidentielle sur un plateau de tokyo
en lumière
hachey alors là nous parlons de
l'élection de présidentielle tout de
même qui pourrait être totalement
inédite pour 2022 et qui pourrait nous
réserver bien des surprises on avait
déjà évoqué dans un éditorial précédent
sur le même thème rappelez vous du
passage richard de barbara pompili dans
l'émission top chef pour nous parler
elle aussi d'écologie
alors à mon sens cette galéjade et
finalement à s'affronter à deux écueils
majeurs
le premier c'est l'incroyable des
considérations pour les français c'est
dire que nous sommes pauvres à le
française politiquement et l'adapter
nous préférions plus d'attention et de
considération à l'élection suprême
finalement parce que le débat serait une
émission sur une émission de
divertissement de grand public et
laurent chabas c est ce qu elles jusqu
ici même en déclarant que l'animateur
vedette donc en la personne de cnn a une
bonne connaissance de la société
française alors on en déduit que ce
n'est toujours pas le cas pour le
gouvernement d'ailleurs benjamin hat
alain qu'on voit souvent porteurs de la
bonne parole de ce gouvernement boute en
train a soutenu lui même cette
proposition on attendait pas moins de
lui alors plus sagement au bout et là le
rapport tragique qui se fait de plus en
plus ténue entre le divertissement et
quoi et la politique mais vous me direz
bien entendu que ce n'est pas nouveau
mais le processus a sert aujourd'hui ses
limites car l'émission de cyril hanouna
est à présent très couvrir le sép la
classe politique et par certains
éditorialistes de toutes sortes pour
décrocher leur rang de serviettes
d'ailleurs sir est le mien a déclaré
récemment il espérait faire de son
plateau un lieu incontournable de la
prochaine élection
voilà l'état du débat médiatique en
avril 2021 et deuxièmement il est
intéressant celui ci aussi parce que pas
sûr que cette proposition ne marlène
schiappa la ministre déléguée à la
citoyenneté enchante les célèbres
journalistes qu'il y a l'orne sur ce
débat prestigieux vous savez olivier
c'est un peu le prix pulitzer du
journaliste politique que d'avoir
l'honneur de co animer ce débat c'est le
saint graal
2 la profession et la ministre déléguée
de la cites a été mariée une chappe à
assen goretti comme on est les grands
médias à la séance de cet entre-deux
tours olivier alors finalement quelles
sont les raisons selon vous de cette
dérive que vous dénoncez ont réitéré ce
traitement du gouvernement que vous
enchaînez les plateaux télé les télés
radios
ben vous comprenez bien que votre parole
un prix me plus auprès de la majorité
des français donnent vous tentez
désespérément d'aller chercher bonne
grâce dans la grand'mare malades du
divertissement un condescendante ainsi
soit il est alors en grosso modo c'est
allons parler aux français la 1100 ses
dires le délitement très sincèrement du
discours politique qui ne passent plus
les portes du périphérique parisien
et c'est déjà le cas depuis un certain
temps olivier et lorsqu'on apprend
finalement gouvernement va dépenser près
de 3 millions d'euros oui vous avez
entendu 3 millions d'euros pour mettre
en place une écoute social j'adore le
terme des coupes sociales sur les
réseaux sociaux et surveiller sa
réputation via une entreprise privée on
se dit que la phase de déconnexion est
totalement est enfin achevée alors tout
vient finalement ne relis ce
gouvernement français et seule la
télévision leur confère une impression
lointain de ce qu'est le populaire et
l'existence des gens ordinaires mais
comme le craignaient ce grand film mais
il disait je le cite l'avenir de la
société et de ne plus pouvoir rien
engendré que des opposants ou bien
débuts et merci beaucoup
nicolas
nicolas vidal gros trou dans l'édito de
la matinale c'est tous les jeudis à tous
les jeudis matin et à retrouver
également sur les réseaux sociaux